know that you secretly love artichokes
and plums keep your voice down
woman this subpar toolbx only had one
wrench so I was lucky it was a three4 or
I'd have been screwed yeah man you are
lucky come on Ron what the hell I need
your help by the time I was done this
100-year-old piece of americanmade cast
iron was singing like a bird now to most
people this story would seem boring
that's ridiculous it's a story about a
radiator but to me it was was immensely
satisfying because I enjoy fixing
radiators you like fixing this town
Leslie you always have you know it's an
uphill battle but you love the struggle
I would also add that you've already
done a hell of a lot to make this town
better and people like this young man
here will benefit from your hard work he
is a beautiful boy he's quite a looker
thank you
Ron what's that
nothing Clear My
Throat all told we were in there about 6
hours and no I was not meditating I just
stood there quietly breathing there were
no thoughts in my head whatsoever my
mind was blank I don't know what the
hell these other crackpots are
doing you really shouldn't have dug that
out of the dumpster I had to also I had
a banana on the way over here sorry and
I get why you don't want anyone to know
about Duke silver and you don't have to
worry your secret is safe with me to
even it out I'm going to tell you all of
my secrets oh no that's not necessary I
once forgot to brush my teeth for 5
weeks I didn't actually sell my last car
I just forgot where I parked it I don't
know who Al Gore is and at this point
I'm too afraid to ask when they say 2%
milk I don't know what the other 98% is
when I was a baby my head was so big
scientist it experiments on me I once
threw a beer at a Swan and then it
attacked my niece Rebecca that'll do
Andrew you don't have to play the Unity
Concert but don't quit music
please
5000 in the
wind ladies and gentlemen Mr Duke
[Applause]
silver
[Music]
the
master you in
[Music]
s
master your 5000 candles and the world
why are you
here come back to
work no come
back I want you to come back well I
don't want to come back the end I was
talking to Andy about you and he made me
realize that I need you back at work
what did he say don't recall fine I'll
come back good
okay I'm
leaving bye
zuu bye Duke
silver my mom has all your albums I
recognize you the day we met have you
told anyone
no good
girl okay so the clue is inside but it
takes the felet code to open Andy did
you
try H yes why is that everyone's first
suggestion just smart people I think I
might be able to help you told
[Music]
you let me see it yeah you can I'll show
you I can unroll it the murals With This
Heart you see look to the first and
there your next clue will be the first
letter of the name of each mural with a
heart on it will spell out the
clue or some or something let's check
out the murals I have had it in a safe
place and then I moved it to protect it
and I don't remember where I see don't
be mad Ron she hit it too good and she
left a string of Clues it's an
impossible puzzle and I love puzzles a
minimal unhelpful note these appear to
be human teeth and what is this Twilight
New Moon it's a movie but I've never
seen it it's like about lame werewolves
and vampires and Stuff Donna likes those
things do to Donuts this points us her
way finally a scavenger hunt worthy of
my time onward Mouse Rat CD
$30 candy bars $50
$50 God people here are so cheap April
where have you been over two phone calls
came in unimpeded we're raising money
for my college education Ron I took a
second job back at my old job do you
want to see shine it's
$100 laugh all you want Kyle I already
took the money out of your wallet
good news son you have just won a Ron
Swanson
scholarship I don't think so I don't
remember applying for any Cy Ron
Swanson
scholarship wait are you
serious stop this no stop or you lose
the
money
hello Diane I have brought you
flowers also
chocolats and some Grout cleaner I
noticed you needed Grout cleaner so I
brought that too very
romantic my kids are non-negotiable Ron
it's a package deal I know I'm sorry
Diane I really
am I've been alone most of my Life by
choice and kids
this is all new for
me but I'd like to become familiar with
it if you give me a chance to prove
myself I did bring the girl
something I thought I could teach him to
saw and now realize that seems
dangerous Hey Ron can I ask you a
question sure it's about April I don't
like to to get involved in people's
personal I heard her feelings and now
she's pissed at me I feel like if I
could just explain myself she'd
understand but she's avoiding me it's
making me
miserable April's in the hospital sick
with the flu what I knew it I didn't
know that is she okay yeah she's fine
you can go visit her tomorrow morning
but don't tell her I told you I
won't no no no no come
here this is the one this is oh why do
you have so many keys we did surgery
just like you taught us okay you know
what why don't you girls clean up all
this hair and I'm going to talk to Ron
let's cut off our t no let's not I'm
going to take this bag too you need to
fix this it's not that bad nobody got
hurt it's extremely bad I love this
woman and I just want to show her that
I'm capable of watching her children
without something horrible
happening what did you just say you love
Diane no I did not yes you did that is
so cute for God's sake Hansen will you
please focus on the larger
[Music]
problem girls girls I don't know what
you think you heard but please don't
tell your mother what you incorrectly
think you heard loves Mommy R loves m I
love
nothing